welcome to this video it's yogurt again
his please my most frequent opponent I'm
totally sure 25 games and I'm on a minus
to score 11 wins 13 roses one draw and
I'm trying to be solid super solid let's
see castles I think I'd play c5 normally
now okay nothing terrible but you can
take on d5 now to go to a queen's gambit
exchange no is he wants to be super
aggressive him hmm energy form can I
take hmm probably hmm i don't like to i
don't like to give him a big initiative
early on maybe I can but let's let's do
call the play in the center if he goes
g5 can i maybe take on deform form for a
piece sacrifice i get two pawns
hmm okay come on let's let's do this
it's interesting he didn't need to take
it I mean I definitely have some
compensation here it's very obvious but
is it enough hmm the night does not have
many good squares
might be five year might be five I have
an interesting choice i can i can also
just takes a form that's not bad yeah
yeah i will able to take before I guess
the night is so offside Oh Bishop d7
there should be seven for Queen 85 right
that I don't know it's both good I think
it's both good now just 96 he cannot he
has really his problems with his
development I go e 5 Bishop you six next
five ok wants to do the knight to e form
maybe I played this a little bit too too
lame I still have a decent compensation
but I probably could have played this
better
okay so i don't really know maybe I have
to do it Bishop e7 here get rid of this
annoyed the move Bishop is six something
that I really want to play or is there
some aggressive way here forward be 5v5
Queen takes Queen t54 pin
could be interesting if he moves before
I can take it and f3 hangs so I'm
threatening rook be hm and maybe I'm
threatening Eve form roof v8 is the the
main threat though you can maybe you can
play Bishop g5 move like that yeah that
that was sort of it look look critical
right so I'm going to take it and f3
hang so i can take this i can also play
what be aid first he says queen is
protected now if i take it here we
should G to wear Esther is the issue
let's start with that
maybe 94 was interesting I have our
heads a super difficult position I mean
it's entirely entirely tactical where he
hid his super truck here so take here
Bishop g2 and I cannot cannot really do
much else so let's take it should g2
there is no counter check here Knight a5
and how crazy it's 95 probably very
crazy Queen go somewhere that's not
going to work
Bishop c6 rupee to where I've got two
pawns for the piece and it's a total
mess I don't know I really have no idea
what's going on
I really I have my doubts about flex
position but maybe I'm not in bad shape
it's it's really tough to say my king
feels relatively safe this this is good
and it's not social it's not so clear
what he's doing now I mean h2 is also
hanging but I'm not sure that I'm
threatening very much yeah okay I have
to move it here right I was thinking
that this is maybe an idea with we
should be form in the mix ok takes he
wants to take no yes yes Knight f6 if i
take so I cannot take time morning
should a six
wow maybe I have to take this I have to
take this yeah
yeah now in this kind of pure tactical
position he's just far far too strong
against I compared to me I know I cannot
do this this was certainly good for
black but yeah I mean I don't know i'm
pretty pretty sure but now i'm
definitely definitely losing both books
are hanging no black resigns he's just
too far too tricky here it was pretty
clear that I think I mean maybe I'm just
uh yeah yeah black black is winning him
but I have to I have to be very very
precise and I didn't do it here b5 is
winning and Queen a five winning back
the peace yeah that's the clearest way
let's see i said i still think in the
game i also had a good good position but
it's yeah I mean it's super super
difficult I went with this and Knight a5
is right yeah I had this hunch but I
couldn't really I cannot calculate that
with with little slow time I went here
cheeks 94 Bishop e7 it's still good for
black but it is yeah obviously obviously
very very very dangerous Bishop the
ADA's what I need to do I didn't really
what I what I really forgot is that she
can cancel long and now the computer
gives why the net Bishop d 8 and then
Rooke g3 yeah that said so impossible
yet here I'm definitely lost yeah it
says his kind of position as a super
dynamic stuff where you have to cut
later all the time and I have to I mean
this opening is really really bad yeah
okay g5 especially I don't know if this
he can also take default I really think
he should have avoided this position and
yeah yeah I could have punished that
with b5 that is really just winning here
Queen back chat and I'm getting this and
this is a pawn for black and totally
overwhelming position yeah thats it's
that that's yeah cannot pass pass these
chances okay thanks for watching